será suficiente su discurso televisado
Para volver a conectar con el pueblo
Hace tres semanas el presidente francés
Emmanuel macón justificó en una
entrevista su reforma de las pensiones
eso no impidió que miles de personas
salieran a la calle el día siguiente
Pero luego de tres meses de conflicto
social el gobierno anunció su voluntad
de apaciguar los ánimos y quiere cerrar
el capítulo de las pensiones
cada vez que algo no sale como él quiere
pasa enseguida otra cosa y
lo llevó hace años
por ejemplo después de las últimas
elecciones municipales que fueron
nefastas para el presidente y su partido
al día siguiente celebró la conferencia
sobre el clima con los ciudadanos y
todos pasamos a otra cosa
después de una serie de viajes al
extranjero en las últimas semanas
incluso mientras el malestar en casa
continuaba Emmanuel ha vuelto a la
primera línea con su popularidad en
caída libre tras la crisis de los
chalecos amarillos lanzó un gran debate
nacional celebrado en la alcaldías de
todo el país pero funcionará esta vez
Esta táctica
[Aplausos]
es muy poco probable que una gira por
las regiones como la de entonces
funcione Ahora tiene que darnos un
diagnóstico y sobre todo dar la
sensación de una lista de promesas que
no sabemos si se cumplirá ni cuándo
otra opción sería reorganizar el
gabinete de makong Empezando por la que
ha llegado a encarnar la reforma la
primera ministra Elizabeth
quizás invitando a alguien del partido
de Centro derecha los republicanos para
sustituirla en un intento por aumentar
su mayoría en el parlamento apenas un
año después de su reelección el
presidente francés iniciará este lunes
por la noche la siguiente fase de su
mandato de 5 años